now we're going to be talking about
something that you know for me is very
very interesting because I'm someone who
is you know is observing especially this
guy and and and that is how you know in
order to you know speak another language
well you sort of have to you know take
on a different sort of personality or in
a different way of expressing yourself
and this is something that I've noticed
in a in Luca you know he's speaking in
Russian to someone or speaking Spanish
German whatever I noticed this this
transformation of some song and I
thought we will talk about this on talk
about this on camera and so for you go
you know what explain to us a little bit
about the difference in your personality
when you're speaking in different
languages and why we do this as well
okay it's a little bit complicated
explain what happens in the brain with
I would say that you know languages I
wouldn't say that a person has a
different personality when
but something definitely changes
you're always the same person but
probably languages it's like a piano
just pushing certain spots speaking a
certain language probably sparkled
something in you that is not you know
sparkled it when you speak another Lane
let me give an example when I speak
Italian what I speak English I'm
different than when I speak okay give us
some example in the languages give us an
example what was the high people I wanna
say I'm gonna put the language you know
so first describe English you know I was
English like when I speak English I feel
confident oh yeah yeah I feel good man
are you more confident than when I speak
my own later you know interest in Italy
at the time
Indy time until I have to be modest or
nothing about modest when I speak
English but if you more confident
there's a threshold there's a limit
between being confident being here when
I speak English if you are you free you
know I don't feel free because I'm not
as free because you always have this
like the society that you know impose
something like a behavior
speaking Russian feel to like this em
affect the body language by the way
visual for you I'll give you an example
Italians people don't mock us but you
know we use gestures when I eat if
asking you what are you doing David
look at my eyes look in my my hands what
are you doing David what do you do if I
ask any time like it's there that's
wrong when I saw that would be the first
thing or if I speak Spanish for example
you know especially eyes and lips in
hands if I speak Spanish for example
would say when I was in Barcelona TCC I
don't really do it come on Mama's in
Houston oh yes Neil get it my so macho
Ino squee Moscow pasamos P bono you
won't say that I won't say that anytime
expressive see it's like to say to
express even anxiety or like all these
states I express them in no way do I
speak Spanish or more like agitated oh
yeah it's like that
no I don't know changes but when I want
I speak Spanish I feel a bit more silly
you know because I've compared to the
English maybe not the silly but it's
more exciting right yeah that's a weak
works for me but when I speak other
languages such as Russian and much more
serious all by friend let's go to friend
robot for in French I know there's some
eye movements and stuff
sweetbreads but tell me where actually
especially the lips you know like the
French for example say how was it
yesterday it's good it's really for you
the show it is right yeah the shoulders
lost like shoulders lips and eyes are
parts of like gone but at least me I
would have I want an act like that in
town I would say she'll never get to
this [ __ ] Allah but all in some rounds
I'm such a better look at though that
would be it's a huge difference what
German German and German that's another
language and particularly I just noticed
I just worked on my favorite I try to
figure out how you know it's so
important to figure out how people look
at me from external point of view and I
just figured out that I'm various here's
so you can speak
authorities are
Sebastien attitude about a rubber
town would be different colors depending
what bunch of motorcycles your bed
gesture scenario and a Russian would be
same thing you speak Russian more
serious like mr. barcelonian others
possession of equal
seems
this is interesting and you know so
looking at these sort of things and one
of the questions that I receive when I
told people on Facebook that you're
going to be here is you know do you
think it's really possible to you know
really get into the mind of another
language and culture if you're in your
home country you know is it something
you can do happen you learn these things
an interesting question you think that
you could get there at 7080 percent
because what really counts is human
beings human beings on vectors and out
we're constantly bring your own concept
here but at the same time I think that
the 20% you can cover the 20% by living
in the country or visiting
understand why he wanted we have
I could speakers all because Mexico
living here made a difference
understanding a number of things that
belong to the French everyday life
Parisian yeah so that 20 percent I would
say that mostly you can get there you
can understand our language of system
our culture works to its native speakers
speaker your manual that 20 percent 20
if you really want to get there you
really want to get to this kind of
native-like fluency as well as me it's
not just about 40 it's not just about
behavior integration integrations that
also comes with living in the countries
and applause yeah it's it's a quest but
it's not necessarily gigantic clock
by
are some living things together here is
absolutely important about [ __ ]
that wire in this soul
and so this comes back to the other the
topic of the other video about how
language is life you know so to get all
of these other aspects right you know
the body language may be the way of
behaving etc it's about making the
language part of your life and you can't
get that from hook yeah you observe it
from an absorbing sir
it's information thank you either if we
can extract some information you find
great ways to extract information from
books but you will never get the
information which is necessary to live a
certain way unless you have contact
my philosophy changed a little bit I was
like you know at the beginning of school
used books and then I waited for two
three four five months
bosses that people say you don't have
words to express yourself it's not
necessarily true because I ask and
little by little you have to try to talk
about Cotton's for philosophy
those are you try that with Polish and
trying that
fantastic okay and so we're going to be
going into this topic in more detail in
the podcast I have recorded with Luca
for the language is culture podcast make
sure you check out the link below and
you can find you know more information
on the other side you can listen to the
podcast about you know why language is
culture with the mentoring and Luca and
burial oh I love things they look
Alabama alright thank you for watching
and we will catch you in another video
ciao